mais bon ce soir
vous avez un look d'enfer lyoen un
incroyable cette fille - vous avez
accouché quand même temps ya trois mois
ben voila tu vois très en forme il a
quel âge
voilà avec des phrases comme ça qui
mérite sa photo ici
bien lit ou d'anglais tant scène pour un
spectacle vous chantez prévert oui je
chante du prêt le spectacle enregistré
sortie en cd à peu près sorti en même
temps que diego d'ailleurs juste un peu
et ça s'appelle coeur de ruby 1 où
j'étais un petit 10 comme ça où il ya
tout votre votre spectacle vous chantez
quad prévert sur ce disque je sens je
chante je suis comme je suis je chante
embrasse moi elle était très jolie
chanson prévert à écrire rouge et noir
n'ont est une bruno sire marin passionné
jean masson le plateau on a besoin de
jeanne mas tu te démerdes
revient très bien
carly
bien alors très bien vous avez une
formidable soit prêt vers c'est j'aime
sa manière de parler de la noirceur de
la vie sans vous dégoûter
cela fait dix ans c'est vrai qu'avec bd
parce que techniquement par les prêts
verts il a fait une anthologie de la
littérature française il était et est
bien classé prévenu frederic à ce moment
là foutez moi la paix
bien alors vous êtes toujours chanteuse
dans clio mais quoi
merci
toujours chanteuse
est une chanteuse lui mais jour une
femme mais désormais animatrice sur arte
vous faites à un magazine féminin qui
s'appelle lola on y parle de quoi liot
des femmes le destin de ces destins de
femmes qui par exemple qui par exemple
des inconnus ah oui mais non c'est les
mecs mais non c'était fiche de juin vous
dit en parlant de la télévision parce
que vous avez des avis sur la télévision
et c'est très bien parce qu'elle est une
citoyenne vous payez votre redevance
nous vous aiderons à lörrach d
amérique et d fondre de lyon cela
dit on a tout loupé avec la télé
pourquoi on a tout loupé avec la télé
parce qu'en fait elle aurait dû être une
fenêtre sur le monde et qu'elle est qu
un outil qui manipulent plus ou moins
bien les gens ouais ouais c'est vrai
vous avez dit
vous avez la télé manipulatrice
propagandistes racoleuse
méprisante bah oui
et des fois vous l'êtes aussi annoncé qu
elle était restée sur le court
parce que lio elle donne aussi des coups
de boule donc lieu où vous avez refusé
nice people malgré dix mille euros par
jour est-ce que c'était au temps où
c'est comme ça à peu près c'était pas
assez cher ouais 10000 euros par jour je
chante en live iq monde on faisait
beaucoup moins
est ce qu'ils ont ils l'ont va proposer
du maïs l'épaule hélas avec ça ce prix
j'aurais réfléchi bah oui ça l'est ça
laisse rêveur un dix mille euros par
jour que les gens ne se disent pas c'est
une onde de refuser 10000 euros par jour
parce que en acceptant ça elle peut
aussi
je ne vais jamais l'euro par jour un
calcul à long terme souhaitons proposer
sinon scandaleux oui d'aller dîner là
bah ouais ouais et alors bah je suis pas
allé je vais déjà un dîner mois
frédéric quand vous leur proposez aussi
non voilà c'est ça que je voulais dire
on n'a pas ça aussi alors j'ai refusé
aussi et j'ai vu à ce moment là qu'ils
avaient pris maïté à ma place
est-ce que marina foïs on lui a proposé
ninon et là c'est la honte
je me rends compte que ma popularité est
au plus bas bah oui mais ça va bien
après le film évidemment je leur ai fait
elle était prête à payer dix mille par
jour
bien fait dix mille euros par jour en ce
qui nous concerne ça aurait fait donc
dix mille francs par jour et par enfant
et c'était c'était pas mal savoir effet
déjoué au petit 1 voilà quand on vous
demande pourquoi vous avez fait autant
d'enfants vous dit mes enfants m'ont
empêché de mourir les enfants m'ont
rempli de quelque chose de merveilleux
peut-être je me sentais un peu vide
ouais vous aviez besoin est rempli par
départ des enfants savent qu'un enfant
oui c'est ça qu'on peut vérifier la
phrase
c'est vrai besoin quand on tombe et
l'autre manque d'amour
voilà c'est comme ça oui c'est bien
c'est ça c'est ça la france n'a pas
comme ça maintenant ça va beaucoup mieux
lio vous avez retrouvé votre premier
amour ouais c'est fou cette histoire
c'est que mais l'histoire était riche et
clio a retrouvé c'est son premier petit
copain à l'école 28 ans après le luxe et
de le lancer de bruxelles à 50 ans plus
tard non mais c'est maintenant à
l'époque il vous disait vraiment tout
petit déjà tué la femme de ma vie c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est dingue
et lui disais on finira notre vie
ensemble à l'époque lio rigoler ils sont
en train de finir leur vie ensemble
jean sur veyle
outre ces écoutes c'est la télé qui nous
a
et c'est parti
jusque là c'est vrai vous le dites
vous-même j'étais pas très très doué
pour trouver le grand amour un banon çà
çà çà çà se saurait si c'est dû à quoi
c'est dû à quoi
si vous êtes trop mou trop romantique
peut-être vous chercher trop un truc
beau et j'ai maintenant je trouve que
dans l'amour iliaque l'absolu qui joue
demain on cherche pas l'habitude
franchement le pire c'était le père de
vos jumelles la visite qu'il a été très
violent avec vous oui oui moi je suis
aller de charybde en scylla oui
exactement
pourquoi en avoir parlé c'est pas moi
qui en ai parlé hier vous savez c'est la
correctionnelle quand on porte plainte
et
et donc les journalistes tout le monde
peut venir dans la salle des codes
correctionnel on peut assister au procès
et il ya des mouchards dans les palais
de justice quand il ya des gens connus
qui se retrouvent en correctionnelle ils
préviennent les journalistes et j'ai eu
droit à une demi page dans le parisien
le norvégien voilà c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé et donc à ce moment là
j'étais pas du tout je n'avais pas du
tout envie d'en parler c'était quelque
chose qui était encore difficile pour
moi mais comme ça avait été fait ben
j'ai préféré me parler m'exprimer et
puis les y ont fait une fois j'ai reçu
tellement de lettres de femmes dans le
même cas que moi que je me suis dit que
j'avais bien fait de le faire vraiment
vous avez dit ces hommes sont des
prédateurs ce type d'hommes qui repère
les femmes blessées et moi à l'époque
vous étiez blessé parce que vous êtes
peut-être moins de succès qu'à une
certaine époque et vous étiez une proie
facile pour ce type de ce type d'homme
c'est ça il ya un processus
effectivement je les hommes qui
qui finissent par battre leurs femmes
d'abord ça se passe dans tous les
milieux il n'y a pas du tout un milieu
où les gens sont plus simples et où ça
se passe plus que dans un autre c'est
vraiment tous les milieux et est en fait
il ya sept ans il ya un processus corps
avant d'en arriver au cou parce que ce
dont j'ai le plus souffert c'était qu'on
se demandait comment une femme comme moi
qu'ils avaient du caractère pourrait
vivre ça donc c'était quelque part je
l'avait bien cherché ou que j'aimais ça
et que donc j'ai peut-être d'une
certaine manière complices et ça c'est
vraiment ce qu'il ya de pire parce que
c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça se
passe son ce sont des hommes qui qui qui
ont besoin de la vitalité d'une femme
qui repèrent d'ailleurs des femmes de
fortes des fans qui sont solaire et qui
au départ leur déclare un amour inouïe
ça a l'air d'être vraiment l'histoire
d'amour du siècle c'est mieux que paul
et virginie
ils ont senti qu'il y avait une faille
en vous qu'à ce moment là vous êtes plus
fragiles bon mois cette époque là
j'avais 36 ans la quarantaine approchait
j'avais raté toutes mes histoires
d'amour je n'avais plus de contrat
j'étais effectivement assez assez assez
mal et au départ ils vous disent que
vous êtes la femme la plus merveilleuse
enfin ça a l'air vraiment vous êtes la
montagne la femme de leur vie et puis
petit à petit la violence des mares
d'abord ils vous fâcher avec vos amis
vous fâche avec votre famille dénigre le
milieu d'où vous venez dénigre votre
passé est toujours très intelligemment
dix ans exactement les choses qu'il faut
et petit à petit vous êtes seuls les
scènes commence en périphérie d'abord ça
casse tout autour et puis finalement y
vous tapez tout de suite après vous
demande pardon et puis vous allez deux
coups en garde ont de quoi en pardon en
espérant que vous allez retrouver les
jolies paroles du début et c'est vous
êtes aliéné c'est vraiment c'est que ça
se passe comme une secte où est ta
lumière quand je demande pardon vous
vous pardonner vous dit ça sera plus
parce que si on pardonne mais je sais
c'est sa mère mon père pardonne et là on
pardonne parce que d'emblée comme ben
oui mais ça c'est évidemment ce qui est
plus difficile c'est de comprendre ça
c'est on a du mal à moi je me suis senti
extrêmement sale dit je me suis sentie
avilit et gémit j'ai vraiment dû faire
un énorme travail pour pouvoir me
regarder de nouveau et on pardonne parce
qu'ils sont en larmes directement après
qu'il dise qu'il regrette tellement mais
qu'ils ont été c'est trop d'amour qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à gérer ça qu'ils ont
souffert qu'ils ont peur d'être trompé
encore et on se dit qu'à force de les
rassurer qu'à force de les aimer et ça
s'arrangera et puis ça ne s'arrange
jamais ça ne s'arrangera jamais et
essayer de mal en pis et la violence et
escalade et vous un moment donné vous
est vidé de tout et vous ne pouvez même
pu réagir qu'est ce qui fait votre
sursaut ce qui fait mon sursaut c'est
que ma soeur n'a jamais lâché
lll a été voir et son ex femme battue a
parlé pendant trois heures avec un
psychiatre qui lui a expliqué le
processus et elle est venue toujours en
douceur toujours la téte et
et elle me raconte elle quand je lui
disais mais non tu sais c'est rien ça va
s'arranger elle me disait tu sais ça
s'appelle la lune de miel ça
recommencera à van dai au début on ne
veut pas y croire et puis et puis
finalement les petites sont nés et
continuent à me taper elle était aux
cinq donner des coups et pour les
enfants un moment donné on a un sursaut
parce qu'on se dit que vraiment le
couple partir n'importe où et un jour je
je suis parti de la maison et j'ai été
porté plainte clio quand la mort de
votre amie et voisine
marie trintignant récupérés par des
féministes au profit justement des
femmes battues est ce que est ce que
vous comprenez ça thierry je vais pas du
tout parlé de maritie excusez moi je
suis désolé je laime d'amour cette fille
je peux pas faire ça comprend moitié
je ne tiens pas d'écrire un livre
ensemble oui absolument un livre
d'entretiens qui aurait dû paraître aux
éditions du cherche midi qui s'appelait
les hommes et les enfants d'abord
sans parler de marie trintignant mais on
a bien compris en lisant la presse que
le problème était né de du fait de
revoir
son ex mari en fait est ce que est ce
que vous donne envie vous avez revu vos
anciens aux anciens marines est ce que
vous les voyez pas
il y en a des enfants c'est un lien
extrêmement fort quand on vous savez il
ya une phrase qui dit quand on aime plus
c'est qu'on n'a pas aimé moi ce que je
crois c'est que c'est qu'à partir du
moment où il n'y a aucune ambiguïté et
bien l'amour doit être suffisamment fort
pour dépasser
vous savez quand on tombe très amoureux
de quelqu'un on a toujours cette espèce
de désir de virginité on a envie d'être
l'unique de ne jamais rien avoir connu
avant on souhaiterait tellement que
l'autre non plus n'est pas eu de vie
avant mais on peut pas le temps passe on
a fait des enfants et l'amour justement
quand il ya de l'amour ça doit aider à
dépasser ça il ya trouvé la sérénité
malgré un passé grâce même un passé
parce que ça nourrit et ça enrichit
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait trouver comme
sujet pour mettre les gens encore plus
mal à l'aise qu'hier je crois que
j'avais mis à dar très hautes bottes
larmes est arrivé je comprends pas plus
un panier des corrections de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un peu de bleu